my ultimate goal is to be the best bull
rider in the world here we go
good night it's important to be good at
what I do because I am the only girl in
the sport mini ball riding people have
said to me that I should not be riding
bulls or they told me to go play with my
dolls they're pushing me to do better
because I'm right here
I'm a girl and I'm rising to the top my
name is Megan Knight I am 13 and I am a
mini border Asian Knights the cowgirl on
buckwheat the toughest young lady in the
nation people think writing is a male
dominant sport because they don't steal
girls doing it I don't really think
about it when I'm bull riding I just
slip past them and I just rise above
them since I started ball writing I've
competed in over 40 events I have
received quite a bit of rewards for what
I do
I should night she is our beat cowboy
honoree and I'm just getting better and
better because I've been working really
really hard and I feel like I'm just
gonna become number one nation takes
[Music]
folks just got stopped bull riding is
dangerous because the bull is muscular
it's fast horns and if you're scared
you're gonna end up getting seriously
hurt because the bull and sense that I
don't get scared when I'm boring because
I mostly just thinking about keeping my
form good and if I get off in the bowl I
just try to run to the gate and just try
to get out the bullfighters help you a
lot they've saved my life a couple times
back tomorrow
[Music]
I got into bull riding because my dad he
traveled everywhere to bull ride and I
always went with him and cheered him on
[Music]
and then when I was seven years old I
got on two mini Bulls and I told my mom
and dad that I just wanted to keep
riding these Bulls
my dad is my coach my trainer and my
mentor because he helps me he works with
me and he also trains with me and he
gives me a lot of tips about my home we
train every night when you do Red Bulls
your moves being crisp can really
determine your safety of your ride so
training and safety is very important
and as a parent and you don't want to
think about getting hurt but you just go
bull by bull I mean in the end you just
hope for the best and ride hard
I think it is pretty cool that MeJA is
the only girl vegetable riding I tell
her the same as anybody else she won't
get treated any different by the boys or
anything she's got to be tough and with
a lot of dedication and hard work she
can go as high as she would like I am
very proud to be knees as dad she's very
tough and determined and it's pretty
awesome what she's doing I feel like
I've become inspirational to girls and
I'm so glad that I'm breaking down
barriers that people have put up for so
long it is very important to believe in
yourself because if you don't you're
just doubting yourself then you've just
gotta believe that you can
[Applause]
[Music]